fabien j'ai beau bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
vidéo d'un patient retrouvé mort dans
les toilettes d'un hôpital napolitain a
eu l'effet d'un électrochoc en italie
une vidéo qui témoigne de la situation
catastrophique justement dans les
hôpitaux dans certaines régions oui
alors tout à fait il ya eu plusieurs cas
justement devait être effectuée au new
delhi pendant l'été c'est à dire jean
réforme hiver par exemple la natation
s'est vu saisir le coup de bol un virus
dont toutes les régions le fait par
exemple que la compagnie n'a pas 17 h et
n'a pas refait le nombre de cellules
prévues par l'état italien et d'autres
régimes qui ont réussi à compléter
justement cet objectif figure on les
paie aujourd'hui la gère un peu mieux ce
qui peut être levée si par exemple ils
restent en commençant john c'est à dire
des zones plus basse en italie alors que
la campagne était en grande difficulté
saab monte on va dire qu'il ya plusieurs
politiques à l'intérieur de l'italie et
selon les régions certaines régions que
fait beaucoup de prévention a peut-être
fermer ses frontières comme la compagnie
mais il ya les hits c'est à dire que
quand il ya trop de canal les hôpitaux
ne sont pas prêts alors que d'autres
régions préfère continuer à mourir mais
par contre on course leurs hôpitaux
alors on a l'impression que la
désorganisation totale vous venez de
dire certains qui certaines régions qui
confine cette région sont actuellement
confinés en italie d'autres pas encore
leur confinement généralisée que je
zappe et quand et veut éviter à tout
prix
vous pensez que c'est une question de
temps oh écoutez dès l'instant où je
vous ai fait qu'on mettait à parler qu'
il y avait une impossible en confinement
puisqu'il dit qu'il n'y aura pas
constamment total c'est en quelque sorte
l'annoncé aussi je pense que par rapport
surtout à noël qui approche qui est une
fête très importante en italie avec on
va dire une grande disparité sur le
territoire énormément une personne qui
justement vivent au nord mais qui
viennent du sud et qui ont besoin de
rentrer chez eux pour les fêtes car
c'est parfois l'unique fois justement
avec qui le montre dans leur ville
il faut que l'état italien trouver une
solution avant les fêtes pour pouvoir
débloquer justement cette fête de noël
donc un bon film en général n'est pas du
tout exclu au moins dans la quinzaine
avant noël qu'elle est
la situation à turin où vous vous
trouvez à turin la situation est assez
dramatique parce qu'il ya énormément de
car actuellement on va dire que le
piémont et la région le plus proche de
la france si un pays qui a été
extrêmement touché
donc forcément il ya énormément de
personnes également qu' qui sont touchés
et dans la région du rhin le nombre de
cas le nombre de personnes hospitalisées
dans le piémont a été multiplié par
trois donc il ya un énorme problème et
une quantité totalement incontrôlable
personnes actuellement et nous on espère
bien sûr que cette situation va se
résoudre plus vite
il ya un autre problème aussi que
beaucoup par furla de patients d'autres
régions vont dans le piémont 11 par
exemple 20 des patients de la ligurie
qui la région juste au sud qui est une
petite review et où il ya énormément de
personnes âgées et bien certains partent
justement dans le piémont parts à turin
où les hôpitaux sont plus gros plus
efficace et donc vous combrée notre
région depuis l'automne les différents
gouvernements ont pris des mesures pour
justement essayer de freiner la
propagation du coc u19 ça a commencé
avec des couvre-feux puis certaines
restrictions des commerciaux ont fermé
on a vu aussi qu'en italie il ya
énormément de manifestations pour
protester justement contre ces mesures
de restriction 1re confinement peut-il
être supporté par les italiens qui sont
déjà éprouvées 1 par le le premier du
printemps c'est aussi le problème par
rapport à l'économie italienne jette une
économie basée sur des petites
entreprises principalement des petites
entreprises familiales qui n'ont pas
forcément les épaules d'une très grande
entreprise en cas de crise donc
aujourd'hui toutes ces entreprises
familiales entreprises alimentaires et
devrait sorbon deux bars ont de grandes
grandes difficultés à survivre durant
cette période après il y aura une
capacité de réponse de réactivité aussi
beaucoup de commerçants l'italien
s'organisent pour travailler avec de la
livraison à domicile avait du travail à
distance
mais il est évident que ce sera très
difficile on a vu justement dans la
région de nabeul que reconfirmant
n'était pas possible pour
comme elle sent que ce serait leur mort
définitive et donc justement c'est ce
qui a porté à rester pour la région
compagnie encore longtemps
beaucoup de ses aventures mais qui
aujourd'hui le pen c'est à partir de
demain elle sera âpre conflit merci
beaucoup fabien gibeau d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant à l'université de turin et
spécialiste de l'italie